One must earn everything they acquire in life.
Life may be free, but living is not and therefore,
we all must work for it.
Working is essential in life, but what’s
important is what kind of work is essential
to YOU.
Working is needed for survival and the acquisition
of personal luxuries, but you must not only
look at work in terms of what it can give
you.
You must also consider what your work can
give the world.
You must consider the world as a massive and
intricate puzzle that you are an individual
piece of.
Find out what piece you are and where it fits
to help complete the puzzle’s image.
Look inward and admit to yourself what it
is that you possess.
What it is that you are good at and enjoy,
and what the world needs from you.
This is the work that we each must dedicate
ourselves to.
In terms of self-purpose in life, it is unlikely
that anyone has a divine destiny, but it IS
likely that life works itself out through
the maze of the world in order to accomplish
the purpose you encode into your subconscious.
Work towards developing that purpose and fearlessly
act on its behalf.
The manifestation of your purpose starts with
undivided belief in it and ends with undivided
attention towards it.
To paraphrase American Transcendentalist,
Ralph Waldo Emerson, “if a man has failed,
it is because he has only dreamt and never
worked.”
It is the pairing of dreaming and working
that provides a person with the ability to
pull dreams out of dream world and into the
real world.
Like a newborn baby, dreams cannot initially
walk on their own.
You must first carry them.
You must be patient and care for them.
Soon, they will learn to walk and soon they
will grow strong and powerful.
By contributing honestly and whole-heartedly
what it is that you have for the world, you
transform work into vitality and wonder.
It becomes mutual for you, the individual,
and the world, the collective.
Working does not have to be a debilitating
thing.
It can be an energizing and satisfying thing.
Look for and uncover what fits your unique
self and follow it to the end of the world.
If done properly, you will be compensated.